have you ever stopped to consider how
many people didn't screw up for you to
be sitting here tonight you know your
ancestors how many times there were
opportunities for you know the
saber-tooth Tiger to strike back or the
hump to fail or the fever to sweep
through or the breast to go dry or how
many times were there opportunities that
somebody had their eye on the ball
somebody paid attention you are the
inheritor of that process there's a lot
of talk in the New Age made about the
Dow of the ancestors or Dow like what is
the doll with the ancestors mean except
that you are the rearranged genetic
component of your particular genetic
stream and your grandfather your
great-uncle your grandmother your
great-aunt had ways of doing things
pitting peaches planting beans trimming
flank steak that's the bow of the
ancestors but there's a way to do things
and that when you do things that way
that is the appropriate way for you to
do it and you can tell us the
appropriate way because there is very
little energy loss that's what the Dow
is it is appropriate activity and from a
psychedelic point of view when we
analyze the state of the world
what we see is not that there are many
problems sexism racism air pollution
monotheism you name it not that there
are many problems but that there's
really just one problem the problem is
well it can be defined many ways but
it's basically that we are inappropriate
to ourselves we are ill with ego we have
a narcissism that we cannot put down the
thing that I learned in studying history
and living life is that the thing that
makes you happy
eventually makes you unhappy everything
flows nothing lasts and this is a hard
truth to come to grips with psychedelic
or otherwise nothing lasts nothing lasts
not even yourself and I I think that
monotheism is appealing philosophically
as a certain economy one God you know
that wraps it up nicely
but you know you've got to be a little
more subtle than that let's take a
Jungian perspective for a moment our
gods are the images that we collectively
empower ourselves to emulate and if our
God is omnipotent omniscient never wrong
always right utterly unforgiving this is
a jerk who needs this we don't need this
our image our deity is pathological our
image of deity is the image of the
cancerous Li unattained ego and until we
do something about this we haven't got
the prayer of a snowball in hell
exhortation is not going to do it and
now time is running out time is running
out the human story is not going to be
allowed the luxury of being a comedy you
know what a comedy is a comedy is when
you've got no choice this is going to be
a tragedy because the cards are on the
table
you know if you drown because this boat
is sinking it's because you didn't
bother to wander over and climb in the
lifeboat that's the kind of situation
where in history is an absolute
nightmare and it can only be redeemed by
us this is this thing about the DAO of
the ancestors you know did all these
people get freeze to death and stomped
on by mastodons and Ethan by
saber-toothed Tigers and ravaged by
disease so you can blow it you with your
Mercedes and your 48-foot television set
that lame you know so so then how does
one what is to be done right the Tolstoy
in question you must establish a level
of authenticity and yourself visa V
reality and then you become a walking
social catalyst regulator mean generator
whatever you want to put it it's it's
authentic understanding without ideology
[Music]